Дорогі дев'ятикласники, вітаю вас на уроці
української літератури.
Мене звати Анастасія Євдокимова,
і я керую промоцією читання
в Українському інституті книги,
тож говоритимемо з вами про читання.
Сьогодні тема нашого уроку - творчість
Тараса Шевченка періоду арешту, заслання,
і після повернення з нього.
Ви пам'ятаєте, що йдеться про чотири
періоди творчості Тараса Шевченка.
Це рання творчість - 1837-1843 року.
Це період трьох літ, тобто ті 3 роки,
коли Шевченко приїжджав в Україну,
з 1843 до 1847.
Тож далі йтиметься від 1847 аж
до смерті письменника 1861 року.
Перша точка, на якій варто зупинитися –
це Кирило-Мефодіївське братство.
1845 року студенти Київського та
Харківського університетів об'єднались
та створили слов'янське
товариство Святого Кирила і Мефодія,
яке ми також знаємо як
Кирило-Мефодіївське товариство.
Засновниками були Костомаров, Гулак,
Білозерський.
З усіма цими постатями ви ближче
познайомитесь на уроках історії.
До деяких з них ми також повернемось
трішки пізніше.
Насправді, членство Т. Шевченка в Кирило-
Мефодіївському братстві доведеним не було.
Для слідства було важливішим, те що його
можна було формально спіймати і засудити.
Реальною причиною були
крамольні вірші – те, чим Шевченко
не догодив тогочасній імперії.
Так 17 квітня 1847 року поета ув'язнили
в казематі, тобто у тюрмі,
а згодом його перевели в
Петропавлівську фортецю.
За цей час, за ці півтора місяці
перебування в казематі
і перебування в замкненому просторі,
під слідством, автор написав аж 13 текстів
Вони присвячені союзникам, тобто тим,
хто також був заарештований.
Цикл «В казематі».
Саме так називається ця група текстів.
В неї входять тексти, які нам добре
відомі: «Мені однаково»
і «Садок вишневий коло хати».
«Мені однаково» ви вже вивчали раніше,
я хочу лише нагадати про те,
що в цьому тексті він присягає на вірність
Батьківщині,
коли каже, що «мені однаково
чи буду я жить в Україні, чи ні,
чи хто згадає, чи забуде мене
в снігу на чужині, однаковісінько мені».
Єдине, що письменникові небайдуже - це те,
що «Україну злії люде присплять,
лукаві, і в огні її, окраденую, збудять,
ох не однаково мені».
Він переймається долею своєї Батьківщини
і про це текст.
«Садок вишневий коло хати» змальовує
досконалу модель життя,
адже «сім'я вечеряє, хрущі гудуть»
і ми розуміємо,
що є цей ідеальний устрій родини.
Цей текст також був написаний в казематі.
Після слідства, Шевченка переводять
з Петербурга в Оренбург
«под строжайший надзор,
с запрещением писать и рисовать».
Тобто із забороною займатися будь-якою
творчістю аж до вислуги.
Тобто Шевченко служитиме доти,
доки не стане офіцером.
Ми розуміємо, що в Шевченка не було
до цього хисту,
тож він був приречений на довічне
заслання.
Я хочу звернути вашу увагу, що
з Санкт-Петербурга до Оренбурга сьогодні
з сучасними дорогами і транспортними
засобами їхати аж 26 годин,
тобто більше доби дороги.
В ті часи ця дорога займала цілі тижні.
Отже, 1847 року Шевченко написав
цей автопортрет, де він постає як солдат
і ми розуміємо, що для Шевченка
солдатчина стала справжнім викликом.
Єдине реальне послаблення – це
Аральська експедиція 1848-1849 років,
тобто відразу після заслання,
куди Шевченка запросили як художника,
який був необхідний
для дослідження територій.
За цей час він написав 200 акварелей і
зробив дуже багато різних замальовок.
Я пропоную ознайомитись з творчістю
Шевченка-художника,
яка на цей період
зазнала реального підйому.
Отже, увага на екран.
Під час Аральської експедиції Шевченко
міг повністю присвятити себе творчості.
Чому? Тому, що він був затребуваний,
власне, як художник.
Він досліджував нові для себе краї, він
писав портрети, він писав те, що бачив,
він бачив те, як готуються до експедиції,
якими незвичайними є ті краї
і все це його дійсно захоплювало.
Ми розуміємо, що спадок Шевченка-художника
передусім складається саме з цих картин.
Прошу звернути увагу
на «Місячну ніч на Кос-Аралі»
і звернути увагу на те,
коли була створена ця робота.
Під час заслання.
Адже в багатьох підручниках з української
мови трапляється саме ця картина,
яку пропонують автори описати.
Він малював побут казахів,
бачите, навіть тигра малював.
До 1850-го року життя Шевченка
було повноцінним.
Він мешкав на окремій квартирі,
він малював, він займався творчістю,
він з'їздив у довгу експедицію,
яка дала йому дуже багато вражень.
Аж поки прапорщик Ісаєв, якого, до речі,
також малював Шевченко,
не доніс на нього про
те, що як цей Шевченко,
якому заборонено і писати,
і малювати, живе так вільно.
Тож після цього, життя Шевченка змінюється
і його відправляють у Новопетровське
укріплення на острів Мангишлак.
Прошу звернути увагу, що шлях
від Оренбургу до Мангишлаку дуже довгий.
Якщо зважати скільки часу їхати було
від Петербургу,
то аж 47 годин тривала
б ця дорога сьогодні.
Це був непростий край,
це була територія сучасного Казахстану,
на березі Каспійського моря.
Шевченко також малював ті краї
і не просто малював,
це був перший художник,
який зобразив Казахстан.
Увага на екран.
В цей час Шевченка чекала
щоденна солдатська муштра,
яка не була в жодному разі простою.
Але в цей час він знайшов глину поблизу
їхньої фортеці і захопився скульптурою.
Жодна з цих скульптур не дожила
до сьогоднішнього дня,
але ми знаємо про те,
що це було в його житті.
Також він пішов у хор, він подружився
із комендантом форту,
до якого часто приходив у гості.
Шевченко малював казахів,
він малював Казахстан.
Шевченко знайшов вербову гілочку,
яку навіть посадив,
яка, зрештою, проросла, як велике дерево.
Для Шевченка було важливо
мати шматочок України поряд
і ця вербова гілочка була її втіленням.
Що таке Казахстан?
Це безкрая пустеля, це 50 відтінків піску.
Це вітряне літо і дуже холодні зими.
Бачите?
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу на Шевченка,
який сидить в колі своїх товаришів.
Той клімат і ті умови дійсно
були непростими.
Шевченко багато хворів.
Тобто, якщо на заслання він їхав молодим
парубком, йому було лише 33 роки,
за час заслання він перетворився на
старого діда, про що писали його сучасники.
За час заслання Шевченко написав
не дуже багато текстів.
Зокрема за цей період перебування
в Казахстані.
Проте, тоді з'явились дуже багато
російськомовних повістей.
До нашого часу дійшло лише 9, хоча
сучасникам він писав, що їх близько 20.
Мабуть у вас виникає запитання:
«чому він писав російською»?
Тут важливо знати, по-перше,
культурний контекст,
адже йшлося про Україну 19 століття
і про те, що йому, в принципі, було
заборонено в цей час писати і малювати.
І те, що він писав російською
мовою, могло, принаймні,
якось пом'якшити його покарання.
По-друге, важливо те, що він планував
повернутись назад,
в культурне життя Петербургу.
І повернутись можна як?
Зокрема через публікації.
Україномовних журналів тоді не було,
тому він розраховував на російськомовні.
І готував спеціально для
російськомовних журналів ці повісті.
Значною мірою повісті автобіографічні.
Найкращим зразком, звісно, є художник.
Як написав про цей текст Іван Дзюба:
«це автопортрет із перспективи часу».
Тобто Шевченко повертався до початків
і писав про своє життя
від своїх перших кроків у Петербурзі,
через потрапляння в Академію мистецтв,
знайомство з тогочасною Петербурзької
елітою, яка принесла йому багато радості.
І ми дізнаємось, власне, з цієї повісті,
яким постає життя Петербургу:
як вони спілкуються, чим вони цікавляться,
які галереї відвідують і що читають.
Ми знаємо більше.
Так само, в цей же час, Шевченко
починає писати свій щоденник,
який називається «Журнал»,
в нього є потреба переосмислити все,
що з ним відбувалась досі,
і подивись на своє життя по-новому.
Що для нас важливо?
Що Шевченко, пишучи цей щоденник,
одразу думав про читача.
Тобто це текст не для себе,
як саморефлексії,
які ми записуємо аби нам стало легше,
аби ми зафіксували якісь періоди, особливі
події, дати, людей, яких ми зустрічаємо.
Для Шевченка це працювало трішки інакше.
Він розумів, що потім життєпис потрапить
в руки читачів і гулятиме Петербургом.
Чому він думав про читача?
Так само аби розповісти про своє життя,
аби показати його,
тобто, чи завжди він був з нами чесний,
чи завжди він був правдивий
- це велике питання.
Так само як і у випадку «Художника»
автобіографічної повісті,
адже він дещо змінював реалії,
а потім після Шевченка в його щоденник,
який називається «Журнал»
втрутився його редактор Пантелеймон Куліш,
але про це поговоримо трішки пізніше.
18 лютого 1857 року помирає цар Микола І
і Шевченко пише лист до Федора Толстого,
аби той допоміг і посприяв
завершенню заслання.
Шевченко не сидів склавши руки весь цей
час, він постійно листувався з друзями,
власне, це його і підтримувало.
Найактивнішою його дописувачкою
була Варвара Рєпніна аж доти,
поки їй прямо не сказали пригрозивши,
що не варто цього робити,
не варто писати Шевченку.
Що його ще підтримувало?
Звісно - творчість.
Шевченко в листах постійно
просив друзів про клопотання
щодо пом'якшення його
перебування на засланні,
аби йому бодай дозволили
малювати – це те, без чого він не міг.
Звісно, це так само впливало
на емоційний стан Шевченка,
не лише на його фізичне здоров'я.
Тож, коли після заслання він повернувся,
як вже сказали, старим дідом,
однією з причин було те,
що він був позбавлений радості життя,
яка називається творчістю.
Так, я хочу ще раз з акцентувати,
що період заслання тривав
з 9 червня 1847 року
аж до 1 серпня 1857 року,
тобто 10 років - від 33 років Шевченка
до 43 років Шевченка.
Чому Для нас це важливо?
Тому що в час, коли він мав бути митцем,
який створює багато
унікальних текстів, картин
який живе у своє задоволення,
який створює сім'ю, спілкується з друзями,
знаходить свій затишок на своїй
землі - він провів цей час у засланні.
Для нас, для поціновувачів творчості
Шевченка, це насправді є трагічним.
Отже, 1858 рік,
Шевченко повертається до Петербургу.
В цей час його товариш Пантелеймон Куліш
починає видавати журнал «Основа»
і Шевченко розуміє, що йому варто
приєднатися також до якихось рухів,
до якихось публікації,
йому варто з'являтись у світі,
про нього не забули,
Петербург про нього пам'ятав.
Тому Шевченка постійно запрошують
на літературні вечори,
до нього приходять в майстерню,
а він жив у той час в Академії мистецтв,
він готує до видання
поезії Тараса Шевченка Том І.
Зрозуміло, що мав би бути,
очевидно, і другий Том,
туди мали б увійти всі тексти, які він
написав протягом періоду «Трьох літ»,
протягом періоду заслання.
Чому? Адже ми пам'ятаємо,
що єдина збірка Кобзаря,
яка вийшла доти - це «Кобзар» 1840 року
і він був порізаний та зацензурований.
Це перша зустріч Шевченка з цензурою
і насправді вона відбулася не лише тоді.
Тож Шевченку не дозволяють видати Том І,
і його творчість періоду «Трьох літ»
і заслання за життя не виходять.
У цей час все таки з'являється
збірка Шевченка,
а її автор заочно засуджений
Російською імперією на смертну кару.
Це один з перших випадків,
коли українських авторів швидше надрукують
за кордоном, ніж в межах імперії.
Про це ми більше будемо говорити
вже одинадцятому класі.
Того року в Петербург
із гастролями приїжджає
афро-американський актор Айра Олдрідж,
ви бачите його портрет на екрані.
Вони не просто познайомились, але знайшли
спільну мову, адже їх поєднує так багато.
Шевченко, як і Айра,
мали непросте дитинство
і нічого не віщувало всесвітньої
слави чи успіху,
адже жоден з них не мав шансу на те,
аби стати професійним митцем.
Так свій шлях Айра почав з того,
що прислужував відомому актору
і зрештою сам потрапив у театр.
Він грав неперевершено,
він збирав щодня аншлаги в Петербурзі,
він грав Шекспіра так, як не грали
доти - і це Шевченка вражало.
Він насолоджувався спілкуванням
з однодумцем
і навіть, коли Айра починав співати,
Шевченко його розумів,
вони розуміли один одного не знаючи мов.
Шевченко активно бере участь у заходах
в цей період,
але це йому трішки заважає, тому що він
намагається зосередитись
на гравіюванні – те, чим захоплювався
він ще раніше,
коли починав навчатися
в Академії мистецтв.
Гравіювання потребує зосередженості,
часу і спокою.
Шевченка постійно смикали різні гості,
різні заходи і він відволікався,
хоча своє визнання від Академії мистецтв
він отримав саме як гравер.
У 1959 році відбувається
остання подорож в Україну.
Давайте пригадаємо, що в Україні Шевченко
насправді прожив не так багато,
адже 1814 року він народився,
лише за 14 років
разом із паном Енгельгардтом
він вирушив у вільне, а потім у Петербург
і це сталось 1828 року.
Тобто з 1828 року
до першої подорожі в Україну, в 1843,
минуло 15 років.
Шевченко не був ці 15 років в Україні
і це саме той період,
у який з'явився «Кобзар»,
у який з'явилися «Гайдамаки»,
«Катерина» та безліч інших текстів.
Тобто він писав про Україну,
хотів бути з Україною,
переймався Україною, не будучи,
безпосередньо, там.
А також не перебуваючи у відповідному
мовному середовищі,
адже Петербург був російськомовним,
хоча українську поезію там,
звісно, розуміли.
От 1959 уроку Шевченко
повертається в Україну,
звісно, це не така насичена, яскрава
подорож, як у період «Трьох літ»,
коли він зустрічався з різними людьми,
ходив в гості до поміщиків,
він замальовував різні
пам'ятки архітектури
і мріяв видати альбом «Мальовнича Україна.
Він насолоджувався тим, що він бачив
і вбирав по шматочках Україну кожної миті,
хоча в цей час - це вже була
втомлена життям людина,
яка 10 років провела у засланні,
яка помітно постаріла,
яка не мала тих амбіцій
і подорожуючи Україною
він передусім хотів побачити свою родину.
Коли він повернувся
на Батьківщину, в місце
звідки виїхав у 1828 року,
він зрозумів, що там, на жаль,
нічого не змінилось
і його родина досі кріпаки.
Він розраховував, що зможе їм допомогти,
коли видасть альбом «Мальовнича Україна»,
але, на жаль,
життя закрутилось, потім було
Кирило-Мефодіївське братство,
заслання і так він не допоміг
своїм родичам.
Тож залишав він Україну, насправді,
зі смутком.
Але попереду Шевченка чекала
остання велика любов Ликера Полусмак,
наймичка, яка служила
в одного з друзів Шевченка.
Вона була надзвичайно красивою,
він присвячував їй тексти,
але для неї він був старим дідом,
попри те, що йому було лише 46 років.
Чому? Тому що хвороби побили його
і він вже не мав того молодечого запалу,
на який, очевидно,
розраховувала Ликера.
Ликера відмовила Шевченку і це
його дуже травмувало.
Отож, крім травм фізичних
і поганого самопочуття,
він мав ще й душевну трагедію,
адже це була його остання можливість,
нарешті, стати щасливим
і знайти своє кохання.
За десять днів до смерті він пише текст
«чи не покинуть нам, небого» -
це альтернатива «Заповіту».
Але якщо в «Заповіті» він
дає розпорядження,
де його поховати, як його поховати,
куди він хоче повернутись,
то «чи не покинуть нам, небого» -
дещо інакший текст.
Давайте прочитаємо і проаналізуємо.
"Чи не покинуть нам, небого,
Моя сусідонько, убога,
Вірші нікчемні віршувать,
Та заходиться риштувать
Вози в далекую дорогу,
На той світ, друже мій, до Бога,
Почимчикуєм спочивать.
Втомилися і підтоптались,
І розуму таки набрались,
Той буде з нас! Ходімо спать,
Ходімо в хату спочивать.
Весела хата, щоб ти знала!"
Тобто Шевченко звертається до своєї долі
і каже про те,
що фінал вже близько і нам пора
збирати вози,
збирати всі наші речі і вирушати
у далеку путь.
9 березня 1861 року Шевченко
відзначив своє 47-річчя.
До нього приходили, його вітали,
але 10 березня він відійшов
вже за межу вічності.
Після його смерті, друзі розуміли,
що хотіли би продовжити
справу Шевченка: назвати щось його іменем,
давати стипендію,
аби це ім`я не забували, а навпаки воно
набирало популярності.
Звісно цього не сталося,
хоча слава Шевченка жива й досі.
Так для нас є важливою дата
22 травня 1961року.
Це дата перепоховання Шевченка в Каневі,
там де він мріяв бути похованим,
а саме на Чернечій могилі.
Так, аби було «і Дніпро, і кручі,
було видно, було чути, як реве ревучий».
Зрештою, на старості років,
Ликера Полусмак також переїхала туди,
в Канів, аби бути поближче до Шевченка,
хоча за життя вона його так і не полюбила.
Але після його смерті вона жила там,
де мріяв жити він.
Тож, давайте підсумуємо.
З 1847 –1857 років тривав період заслання.
За цей час Шевченко написав цикл
«В казематі» поки перебував в тюрмі,
у Петербурзі, «200 акварелей»,
подорожуючи Аральським морем
та 9 російськомовних повістей,
які дійшли до нашого часу.
З 1857 до 1861, тобто до
останніх днів поета,
тривав пізній період його творчості.
В цьому розрізі ми говоримо про
автобіографічний вірш «Доля»,
який розглянемо на наступному уроці,
про останню подорож в Україну,
яка, на жаль, не принесла йому радості,
а також про смерть і перепоховання.
Перевіримо наші знання.
Яка повість Тараса Шевченка є
найбільш автобіографічною?
А – «Варнак», Б – «Музикант»,
В – «Художник», Г – «Назар Стодоля».
Правильна відповідь, звісно,
В – «Художник».
Адже Шевченко писав про перші роки
в Академії мистецтв.
З цього переліку випадає
лише «Назар Стодоля», який є драмою.
Наступне питання.
Цикл «В казематі» Т. Шевченка присвячено:
А – декабристам,
Б – ув'язненим кириломефодіївцям,
В – загиблим у російсько-турецькій війн,
Г - українським гетьманам.
Звісно, проаналізувавши,
ми для себе зрозуміємо,
що цикл «В казематі» він присвятив
своїм побратимам,
своїм союзникам ув'язненим
кириломефодіївцям.
Дорогі дев'ятикласники, чую дзвоник.
Це означає, що наш урок завершено.
Дякую вам за нього.
Приємного вам читання Тараса Шевченка.
Відпочивайте на перерві.